For the visualization, countries and player were encoding along the x axis.
Time encoded along the y axis.
Goals Scored was encoded by the size of the circles.
And the Top Scorer was encoded by color hue, which was yellow.
And now, let's see on the graphic.
We can see that time is encoded along the y axis.
Country and player is encoded along the x axis.
The number of goals is encoded by the size of the circles,
indicated by this legend and
the top score is indicated by color hue, which in this case is yellow.
Now I know this might seem trivial, but these were deliberate choices.
The person who designed this graphic,
thought very carefully about the most important variables.
And how to place them in the graphic, and represent them visually.